if you're going to a party for the
holidays i'm gonna highly recommend that
you bring mandel bread with you people
won't know what it is but once they
taste it they'll never forget it
hey i'm danielle and today i'm going to
show you how to make my jewish mondale
bread or how it's pronounced in yiddish
mandelbrot so i know it's called mandal
bread but i and my family would consider
this a cookie it may not be shaped like
your usual cookie but it's sweet and
delicious and it's just my favorite
thing in the world this recipe is really
important to me my sister's best friend
jody her mom passed away from breast
cancer so i gained another sister that's
essentially what happened but before she
passed away she gave my mom her mom's
recipe for mondale bread and so every
time i make it it's like me saying
you're welcome in my home
once all your ingredients are in there
you're going to take a spatula and kind
of combine them and once they're a
little bit more combined you ditch the
spatula and you do my favorite part and
you just get in there with your hands
make sure everything is mixed and
distributed and your hands are extra
nasty because that's the way you get the
best muscle bread it's kind of fun to
shape the mando bread because it's a
really wet dough it sounds gross but
it's super delicious so for the
strawberry jam mango bread you're going
to want to make a shallow well and kind
of give it edges so that when you spread
the strawberry jam it doesn't fall out
the side so once that's done you put the
strawberry jam on you spread it around
and be generous because it's delicious
and then you'll take the other half of
your dough and kind of spread it on the
top you kind of can't really spread it
out that evenly but that's why you leave
a little extra in the bowl so that you
can cover all the cracks it's kind of
like a puzzle piece because you have to
get the top all together and you want to
seal it up so that the jam is dripping
out you can basically put anything you
want into mondo bread people like
walnuts in it you can make them apple
cinnamon flavor different types of jams
so my favorite mondo bread is the
strawberry jam but the chocolate chip is
a huge hit also when i'm feeling like
i'm far away from home i used to make
this for my college friends to kind of
bring people together and just make
everyone feel like family it doesn't
matter what time of year it is it's
especially fun to make during hanukkah
because there's plenty of oil in it
i personally like my mandala bread a
little soft like not undercooked but
just on the cusp but if you want it a
little crunchier if you're a crunchy
cookie person then i would recommend
leaving it in a little extra once your
mondo bread is out of the oven you want
to let it cool for about 10 minutes
before you transfer it onto the cutting
board don't sleep on the cinnamon sugar
because the cinnamon sugar is the cherry
on top of this damn good cookie
this recipe makes me so proud because
it's not my recipe but it's my family's
recipe and it's jody's family's recipe
and it's honestly to me the best way to
bring people together what brings people
together more than cookies really
anything goes here make it exactly how
you want it and share it with your
family because i can never get enough
strawberry jam i like to spread
strawberry jam on my strawberry jam
mandal bread it's delicious and also
adding a little whipped cream i mean you
can't beat it for the chocolate chip
mondo bread the best possible way to
enjoy it besides on its own is dipping
in an ice cream
this is the way to celebrate the
holidays every time i make it it's like
me saying you're welcome in my home
anytime oh yes
you